Thanks everybody for coming.
I'm really excited for this talk,
that surveillance going to do for us.
Uh,
we have a few people here from Cervelo.
I had stu,
David and Shawn,
less steel and Dave will be doing most of the talking.
We also have Sarah p on piano and who's here,
who just finished Kona,
second American woman.
Very exciting.
And we also have under it oh glue from beyond Arrow who works with,
he's been working with Mila for about 10 years now I think in various aspects.
So he has a bike shop at beyond Arrow and I'm going to turn it on over.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Hi everybody.
Thanks for having us here today.
My Name is David and this is stu and we're designers from Cervelo.
Um,
we just got back from Kona,
Hawaii,
um,
pretty tough job
where we launched our new p five x,
which is our top and triathlon specific bike.
And what we want to do today is take you through the design process of that bike
and some of the cool features that we have on that project.
So to start,
uh,
we'll,
we'll take you back three years ago,
um,
when we first started this project,
we had our p five triathlon and tt bike on the market.
And for us,
that bike was originally designed primarily as a TT bike.
Now is anybody here watch the Tour de France?
Yes.
So you know,
in that,
in that circuit of racing,
you have a section of the,
the event where you're individually racing bikes on your own and you're being
timed on how fast you do that.
But for that rider on the left,
the,
you're,
you're essentially getting out of the team bus,
but getting put on your bike,
you do your event,
you get off the bike and you know,
you're back in the bus kind of thing.
On the right,
we have a travel Martel doing a triathlon.
Uh,
he's one of our pros on the same bike and you can see the positions,
right?
Or actually quite similar,
but the usage is very different.
Trevor,
he's got a pack his own bike,
get it to the event.
He's got to carry all his tools and all his food on the bike with him.
Um,
he doesn't have a team bus,
um,
at the end of the day.
Um,
so there's a lot more going on for that rider.
And we realized that,
you know,
this,
the p five was doing these two different,
very different purposes and we wanted to try and address triathlons
specifically.
We saw there is a need there.
So the goal for this book,
for this project was essentially designed the ultimate bike
and,
and that's really how we started.
Very wide open project goal.
So then how did we start?
Uh,
yeah,
so I'm trying to start from scratch.
We started data mining is the way to go.
We went to through studying the rules of triathlon.
So there's many federations across the world that have slight changes in the
rules depending on,
on where they are.
So we wanted to make sure that we knew what we could do with the bike from a,
and actually have them be able to race them.
Uh,
we studied,
uh,
triathlon courses across the world.
We interviewed retailers and,
uh,
we also interview industry experts.
So we went to a few different,
um,
triathlons,
again,
globally,
trying to capture the essence of triathlon and Ironman,
um,
across the,
across the world.
Um,
and we,
we,
uh,
we took some,
we took actually a 15,000 photos of different writers at all of these races,
all at a side view.
Uh,
some examples we can just fire through and you can see that there was some,
some very unique setups and each rider is quite different and it's some,
some of the things that we've noticed throughout those 15,000 photos,
uh,
very unique stuff.
So even even,
um,
I'm surprised we didn't see a Google bike,
uh,
and one of these races.
But,
but yeah,
people like to do these races for a,
you know,
for charities,
which is,
this gentleman has done,
um,
I may,
ironman Nice.
Um,
iron man.
He's one of the,
one of the most challenging bike course races and he ended it on this bike,
so,
so pretty cool.
Also lots of storage.
So we've got some good ideas for that as well.
And,
uh,
so from these pictures we were,
we really wanted to use them to develop and capture some objective data,
some data that we could use throughout the development process.
Um,
so again,
we took pictures from the side view,
so we were able to compare every single picture,
Tu,
Tu to all of the others.
Um,
regs,
for instance.
Uh,
we could determine where people stored a nutrition and they're flat gets on
their bikes.
So here we have a,
just a list.
I don't know if you guys can read that bunch of different areas on the bike
where people stored bikes and we'd try to determine the percentage of,
of each of each preferred area for storage.
Um,
you can just flip it.
Yeah.
So here's an example of a data that we were able to use forward in our,
uh,
in our development.
Uh,
we discovered that the most common placement for storage or for nutrition in
this,
in this case was on the front of the top deep.
Um,
and so that's,
you know,
development,
development and result.
Um,
okay.
Alright.
So we also,
um,
study those photos along with the interviews of athletes and,
and industry professionals to determine,
uh,
how many,
how many bottles people rode with on the race week.
We found out that,
uh,
you have this graph shows a,
you know,
there's actually 8% of people for those of you have done trap on this gentleman
said he had done a couple.
Um,
there's people out there that's that ride with no bottles,
no hydration,
just pretty interesting.
But I'm not sure how you feel about that.
Um,
there was obviously more,
more commonly,
there was one bottle,
33% of people carried out of,
out of t one,
two bottles,
46%,
three bottles,
12%.
So almost a hundred percent of the people would carry up to three bottles.
So that was something we were able to use going forward as a benchmark.
We were also able to,
um,
this was pretty,
cause this is kind of my favorite part of the data analysis.
Um,
we're able to hit these,
these side view photos and calibrate them to uh,
um,
basically overlay them and actually measure,
geometry.
Uh,
or sorry,
fit.
Um,
so he,
as an example,
we could,
we could find the seat post relative,
see post height and the CFO and I'm sorry to satellite and see posts angle,
um,
stack in reach of,
of up to,
of all the writers in our,
in our,
in our data set.
So really good,
useful information,
real information that we were able to make sure that we catered to in the
development.
So,
um,
this gentleman here was a,
represents our most common like set up.
Um,
we see he's,
he's one of several in his category and not that many.
Um,
and what he is his Arrow bottle between the arms,
a Bento bag behind the stem,
a bank behind a saddle and a round bottle on the down tube.
So that's,
those are four things that were most commonly used and placed on the bike.
Um,
throughout our,
our analysis.
And how,
I got a question for the people in the audience here.
How common do you think that that most common setup was out of,
out of all of the,
uh,
the selected photos that we,
that we studied.
Can anyone guess 95%.
Was that
on the,
on the right track?
Yeah,
it was actually less than 4%.
Right.
So yeah,
our senior engineer used to present this part and he would kick the guy that
said 95% out of the room because he was,
he was,
uh,
he was so off.
But no,
you can stay.
Um,
right.
So three,
3.8% had that,
that set up.
So what did that tell us?
Oh,
sorry.
And,
uh,
I'll,
I've,
all of the setups that we,
that we studied,
there was 688 unique,
unique configurations.
And so this was again,
something we want to use moving forward.
We knew that the bike that we designed for triathlon,
you needed to accommodate a lot of different needs.
Uh,
nutrition.
We wanted to make sure that we had enough nutrition on the bike to support,
um,
a full ironman distance.
Uh,
we designated a volume in the,
in the top tube area for that could hold the almost 1600 calories of nutrition
and of course,
um,
three bottles that can be filled with,
uh,
with added calories.
Um,
we also know that we need,
uh,
in race scenarios and training.
We also need to bring our flak gets storage.
Um,
so we,
we designated a certain,
uh,
this is,
this is what we decided that we need to fit on our bike for an ironman race.
So,
um,
again,
after studying,
um,
users objectively,
after speaking to industry professionals and uh,
and studying courses,
um,
we,
we created a scope for the project and the scope is actually basically seven
main priorities.
The first being we needed a modular and integrated design.
Something that could fit all of those options that people,
that people really with that wanting to ride with.
But with the performance control that we,
that we wanted to gain a,
we want to use round bottles.
Something that we realized was,
um,
uh,
consistent across all the races across the world.
We want it to be easy to fit,
um,
just so that people can stay in their position and really actually stay true to
our performance claims go faster for longer.
We want it to be easy to adjust and we want it to be sorry.
You want to be easy to adjust,
uh,
after fit.
So,
um,
we want it to be easy to pack as well.
Um,
because of travel being a major,
major proponent to the cycle.
And funny,
like interestingly enough,
our six priority was aerodynamics and our seventh was stiffness.
Um,
so,
and that's where we started.
So then again,
the question is how do we start from there?
Um,
so if you look,
go to the next slide.
Does anybody know what these are?
Right?
So,
so this is a,
a set of governing rules and boxes that are applied to UCI regulated bikes and
um,
that applies to any bike that's in the Tour de France or other races like that.
And so every frame Max manufacturer has to fit their bike inside a set of boxes.
You can move them around a bit,
but they have to be of a certain dimension and it has to be a tube in every box.
So if you look the next and the next slide,
um,
are p five is actually very driven in shape by these boxes.
So you can see how closely it actually fits to those box shapes and really
governs how we created that shape of that bike in triathlon.
It's not governed by UCI regulations.
So we did not have that starting point.
Um,
it's very challenging still to design,
uh,
a fast and efficient and good bike within the UCI rules.
But it does give you a place to start.
You know,
there's going to be a tube in every one of those boxes.
When we started this bike,
we didn't have that starting point.
We had a blank piece of paper.
And so in some ways that was almost more challenging.
The freedom was really nice for as a designer.
But the challenge is trying to figure out,
you know,
which one of the ideas to go with.
So we needed some starting points,
some sources of inspiration to come up with how to,
how to make the shape of the bike.
Um,
so one place that we started is a structural analysis and we used a tool called
topology optimization.
And what that is is it's a computer software algorithm that gives you a sense of
where material is really important in a structural volume.
So what we did is we created,
just go back one,
we created this volume of space that's shown there,
a semi transparent and that represents the part of the frame that that's part of
the space that we can use for frame material that doesn't interfere with all the
wheels,
the cranks,
the riders' legs.
And then to that shape we apply loads that represent riding loads in real life.
So you know,
the twisting of the frame,
um,
due to writing.
And then what the software does is it actually takes away material that isn't a
highly loaded or highly stressed and it actually removes that material and then
reruns the simulation again and it keeps eating away at material until you're
left with just the most essential material to meet that load case.
So you can see in this little animation here,
you start with a big block shown in blue and actually sort of erodes away at the
material and you're just left with the key bits of material that are most
important.
And so that gives us a sense of maybe where we should have material on the bike.
So you see a very strong connection between the head tube at the front of the
bike down to where the cranks are,
and then a very low rear end to the back wheel and then kind of this diagonal
member off to the seat.
So the,
the question was,
um,
how do we address the directionality of using carbon,
versus,
uh,
a material like aluminum,
which is continuous in all directions.
Um,
so in this case we're doing,
uh,
what we found is it's too complicated,
complicated to try and apply that at the initial stages.
So what we do is we do a sort of a simple aluminum light case and that tells us
where the material is important.
Um,
but we still later have to go and optimize our layup and figure out,
um,
how we apply the carbon to that.
Um,
so really again,
it's just a source of inspiration.
Like generally what are we looking for in the frame?
Okay.
Um,
and the next slide you can also see another version of the output where you can
actually force it to provide you with a trust structure and see what that would
look like.
And you can kind of see the,
the essence of maybe a loud motorcycle frame there in that version.
So then how do we turn these into actual designs?
So in the next slide you can see a number of the different directions we were
going with the concept.
Uh,
in the top left we have a frame that's sort of a literal translation of that,
um,
topology optimization,
uh,
turned into a frame.
Um,
but then at the same time,
we're also looking at parallel development streams where we're saying,
okay,
well what if we just want the most aero bike?
Um,
we see frames there where we're taking a p five and just adding surfaces to make
it more arrow.
Um,
we're seeing other ones there where we're looking at a usability of the bottles.
Can we drop them in just like a cup holder in a car?
Um,
we are even looking at compliance and whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing.
So what we found though is there was a,
we kept running into this issue of where to put the round bottle on the frame
and it actually became more driving to the design than we expected.
Um,
we have this bottle that we wanted to incorporate into the frame,
um,
but we realized that we needed material around it and we couldn't interfere with
the riders' legs.
So we,
in the end we,
we sort of had three different approaches to that problem.
Um,
the first being,
uh,
the material below and behind the bottle like this.
And then the second sort of going around the bottle on either side and then the
third being in front and above the bottle,
which is what you see in front of you.
Um,
there was a lot of potential in some of the first ones,
but there we were getting structural challenges with having enough stiffness in
those systems.
So,
um,
in the end we went with this approach,
as it gives a good connection from the seat post into the head tube,
a good connection from the head tube to the down tube,
but also has this nice volume in here that we can use for a bottle or additional
storage with a horizontal bottle.
So through this process we want it to just highlight a few neat,
um,
tests that we had to do.
Quite often we'd have a concern or an idea that came up and we'd need to quickly
test it,
um,
and not just speculate on what,
how it might work.
Um,
so there's a few cases here.
The one shows we're testing two things here.
Um,
you may know the sort of ideo approach,
which is a rough,
ripe,
right and rapid for prototyping.
And this is kind of an example of that.
It's very rough,
but it gives us a good test and we did it very quickly and got a good answer
from it.
So we're filling in the entire frame because we wanted to test the effect of
side area.
We knew that we were looking at designs that had more side surface area to them.
So we did a number of ride tests with that.
And at the same time we've also got a bottle cut in half and taped to the side
of that.
And that allows us to move that bottle around in space and find out the highest
we can mount a bottle without interfering with the riders' legs.
So we'd had a number of writers try that.
We created this volume for each rider and now we know where we can put the
bottle.
Uh,
this is a test we did where we instrumented,
um,
an athlete's bike.
And so we had power,
a Yang or speed gps,
but we also had this video on board.
And one interesting thing we were able to look at was we could scrub through the
video and find out how often he was in the extension position.
I want to how often he was in the base part position.
Um,
and as we know,
being in the extensions is much more Arrow and you save a lot of energy being
there.
Um,
so it was an interesting exercise in perception because he thought he was sure
he was in at 95% of the time,
but when we went to the video it was a lot closer to 60%.
And so we realized that we needed to find out why he was doing that and also the
importance of creating comfort in that position so he could stay there.
We also did some testing for storage,
ease of use in terms of the position and keep in mind we didn't have an actual
frame is uh,
is,
was so unique that we,
we were,
we were having to work on all of these tests with a fives.
We had cut up our,
our,
our old Pete fives and uh,
and tried to place them in the most accurate position to the new bike or to our
concept at that point where that,
where the storage would be in that,
in that concept.
So you can see we,
we,
we would cut the top tube right off,
lower it down to the place where you'd see now on,
on the,
on the bike room.
And then we'd have people test out the ease of use in terms of,
at that point we had an idea where we would put storage inside of the frame and
we wanted to make sure that people could access it and that justified things
like,
which we'll talk about later in terms of the features,
but making sure that the top section was relatively pliable so that someone
could get their handed.
We also tested the idea of putting the volume down near the BBI,
under the,
under the down.
Um,
and we wanted to make sure that,
that,
how that we knew how that would affect the ride experience,
if it would affect it at all.
And also,
um,
design,
I guess design ideas.
I was too,
you know,
what side the doors should go on or will it make any noise or things like that.
So,
and of course we did a,
we did some when we did get our first,
uh,
frames together.
We did some initial product testing with,
uh,
with some of our pro athletes.
That's,
this is Sarah,
that Sarah,
um,
and she,
she's a,
she,
she's kind of smiling in that picture that she's come pretty fast.
So we,
we've,
we've got some really good feedback from our pros at this stage as well.
I'm just making that final tweak,
validating,
um,
that we're ready for her,
uh,
for production.
Okay.
Yeah,
right,
right from the beginning,
you know,
Sarah was there and our first engineer hears and then right at the end,
down to the last,
the last development cycle.
We know she has,
they're giving great feedback.
Um,
so we'll take you through,
uh,
the features of the bike.
Um,
and I wanted to start with the bottles because that was again,
as I said,
a big driving factor.
So what we ended up providing,
um,
again,
round bottles,
um,
so that it's very easy to grab and throw away bottles during the race.
Um,
you're not committed to a fully integrated Arrow bottle that you don't want to
lose.
So we got a round bottle between the arms.
Just really nice.
Can Be Very Arrow and sort of reminds you to drink as well.
Um,
we have a bottle here positioned horizontally,
um,
and which is nice for access but also gives this option for additional storage
box.
If you don't want that box or you want a more traditional a bottle angle,
you can mount it like this on the down tube.
Then at the back we created a,
a single bottle rear mount,
um,
which has a very aerodynamic position.
And um,
we also provided,
uh,
like it's fully integrated and built into the seat post,
so it's very stiff.
Uh,
it also articulates and slides in and out so that you can get the bottle at the
angle and the distance that you like.
Yeah.
In terms of top two stories,
so,
um,
where we designed was a,
a two part,
a top deep storage system,
which we call the smart pack.
It's got an upper section,
which is um,
a rubber material.
It's a semi rigid to hold the form I,
while not in use,
um,
of the bike.
But while in use,
you're able to,
uh,
pry it apart and reached down into the second section located inside of the
frame.
Um,
it also has a designated a pill tray located in the rear and kind of see it in
the picture and some side pockets.
Um,
just for,
again,
just to give people options.
A lot of people are pretty unique.
Their,
with their nutrition needs.
Some people make their own even,
um,
and they,
and they pack it certain way.
So we,
again,
we just provided these optional things that you could add in or take out.
You could also even run the whole thing with.
Um,
there's actually a door that blocks off the internal compartments.
So if you were,
if somebody that didn't require as much nutrition,
they could,
they could do that.
And it's alternatively,
they could also remove the upper section,
um,
and just run the,
uh,
the in-frame compartment.
Okay.
So the in-frame storage,
um,
actually I can just talk to them.
We call that the stealth box and that's essentially where we've designated the
area for,
um,
for our flag kit.
It's got an optional,
uh,
internal case,
which,
which you can fill with,
with all of the items that we determined in our research.
Um,
and then you can also remove that back at back piece and just run the door alone
and,
and essentially pack more items inside of the frame.
Things like tubulars in the,
in the case where people would be writing tubulars are they want to bring,
um,
a large pump or something.
They can,
they can put it inside the frame and uh,
and uh,
and still have enough space sandwiches,
subway sandwiches sometimes.
Um,
and in those cases where you might need that storage for your whole sandwich,
you could put the,
your,
the rest of your flag kit inside of the speed case,
which is an optional a case as David described.
And that's just a same whoop.
That's not good.
The same a side door loaded a plastic case.
Um,
yeah.
And so,
yeah,
so these are,
these are the storage areas which we've essentially,
um,
decided on based on that research and our user testing.
Um,
essentially trying to provide as many options as possible while controlling our,
uh,
our performance and our aesthetic.
Um,
so a question that often comes up now that people have seen the bike as,
why are we using disc brakes?
A big part of that we really,
you know,
there are road line is going towards disc.
Um,
we really want to bring that,
that control,
that power and um,
consistency in all weather conditions that you get from disk breaks into the
triathlon market.
Um,
so there was,
there was no question there for us that we wanted to do that at the same time.
Um,
what's really neat is it opens up new design opportunities for the bike itself.
the system is now changing a bit and so we can change how we design it.
So,
uh,
because we don't have a,
a room break up at the top of the fork,
um,
this area is now much freer in terms of design.
So we can clean that up.
Derek,
aerodynamically.
Um,
we can also create a much stiffer front end because there isn't a break inside.
They're using up space.
And it also helped us achieve our adjustable front end that I'll show in a bit.
Um,
we're also,
uh,
the,
the frame is designed,
um,
or optimized for electronic shifting,
which is sort of the way that the components are going these days.
Um,
it's still works with mechanical shifting as well.
but what we wanted to do,
um,
a number of the electronic systems,
uh,
the wiring comes into a junction box.
Um,
and so one element that we wanted to conceal that,
um,
but you know,
there's still,
uh,
a rubber,
a window at the top and then you can see the battery of life,
uh,
for that box.
Um,
and then you can also access it by unclipping the back.
and then you can charge it that way as well.
So we wanted to sort of conceal that element but keep it very user friendly at
the same time.
Um,
so now the front end of the bike,
um,
which is probably my favorite part of the system.
Um,
we really wanted to prioritize the adjustments that we wanted people to be able
to make and make after that.
First fitting so they could change their fit throughout the,
throughout the season as they got more flexible or got back into that position.
Um,
so our first priority was the vertical adjustment of the front end.
So how high or low your arms are.
Um,
and we wanted that to be very easy to make.
So we said,
what,
where else on the frame do we have a really easy vertical adjustment?
Well,
sorry,
the,
uh,
the seat post,
um,
the seat post.
So we have a wedge clamp,
um,
which you adjust with a formula Allen key and it slides up and down.
So we essentially took that same concept and applied it to the front.
Um,
so we have,
uh,
you access it through a hole in the front.
There's a formula Allen key that you would grab you and be the wedge clan and
then you can adjust that up and down,
um,
very easily.
Um,
for those that haven't had a tri bike in your life before,
that's a very unique thing to have that kind of adjustment.
Very often you sort of committed,
once you pick here,
you're fit to,
that's where you're going to be.
Um,
so in the video here,
you can see that that vertical adjustment,
um,
as the first priority.
And then there's also,
you know,
for craft any note adjustment of the pads.
So you can see it flipping there to get a very large range of pad adjustment.
There's width of the pad that you picked by bolting in a different increment.
Then the extensions,
um,
are,
are just a clamped cylinders.
So they're very easy to pull in and out and trim to the length you want.
And then the base bar down here,
actually,
it can be flipped up or down and you can see on this frame is flipped up.
And this one it's flipped down and gives you a choice at the time of cabling the
bike,
whether you want a high or low based bar tilt adjust as well.
Yeah,
we didn't,
we didn't mention that in there,
but,
uh,
on the [inaudible] we weren't able to pitch up and down because a UCI rules say
that you have to have horizontal arms.
So,
um,
but it's quite a nice feature to be able to just tweak that a little bit and
sort of lean into the front end.
So there's two bolts in the top and you can just dial in that,
uh,
that pitch of the front end as you like it.
So,
um,
another feature that you may have noticed if you looked at the bikes is the bars
are actually split and they're made in two halves.
They're not just flippable,
but they're actually two halves.
And that allows for some neat things when you get to,
um,
traveling with the bike.
And so we'll show that here.
We really wanted to create a complete system,
um,
to help reduce that stress of,
of getting your bike to the race,
right?
So you can see that we did that actually,
the idea of creating a bike that was optimized for travel was,
was essentially,
um,
you know,
dumped from the beginning and our scope and obviously shown in the collapsible
bars.
Why else would we do that?
And a show show you and this likened helium four bike bag,
oops,
sorry.
Um,
we were able to collapse the bars off to the side,
um,
by removing four bolts and a and a plate.
And actually with the same ease of adjustability of the whole front end,
you're able to release it just like a seat post,
remove it,
um,
packet in front of the bike and it's all strapped into place with um,
some custom neoprene.
Formal did a protective padding that we developed a alongside of a Canadian bike
render,
biking,
uh,
to create that full,
um,
triathlon travel hacking solution.
So
directly related is a adjustability,
the ease of adjustability and the ease for travel.
It's only six bolts that you need to,
um,
to access in order to pack the whole bike and one bolt for the rear derailleur.
But in terms of the bike and direction,
it's one tool,
four millimeter tool,
um,
can be done in a few minutes.
I don't know.
I don't know if there's anyone here.
Um,
does anyone have any horror stories for packing their bike?
A couple of people.
So a lot of times,
again,
a jug adjustability and packing go hand in hand.
Um,
when,
when the bike is not very easily adjustable,
it's likely not very easy to pack.
Um,
another couple of features of this bike bag is,
um,
he uses a airbag protection on either side,
which allows you to,
I guess,
provide that secure that's secure,
fit for all of the parts and also allows you to pack two sets of wheels and
still maintain underweight.
Right.
Do we make it through underweight?
Yeah.
Awesome.
So this is,
this is actually a was bite.
This is a world champion bike.
Still got the tag on it.
It's still got the sweat on it and everything.
Really trying to I guess
support the,
uh,
the full triathlon experience.
And this is sort of the icing on the cake with all of the other features that
we've,
that we've tried to bring into the bike.
This is sort of that,
um,
that,
that last check.
Um,
so providing a solution for,
for travel,
the full travel experience to,
to bike wheels,
full bike,
um,
all,
uh,
altogether and,
and,
and no loose parts.
Um,
so just reducing that,
that stressor in the,
uh,
in the triathlon racing experience.
And that's it.
Um,
so manufacturing,
uh,
we're just going to touch on quickly,
but it's actually pretty key part of this project.
Um,
we knew that with a design like this,
we really had to,
um,
work with very strong partners,
people we could collaborate with.
Um,
we also knew that there was a concern with Ip for the bike because it was such a
unique shape.
We didn't want it getting out before launch.
Um,
so we wanted a factory where we were more exclusive and uh,
had really strong partners.
So we,
we part,
we're partnered with two of the industry leaders,
um,
in,
in manufacturing,
in um,
front end design as well and wheels.
Um,
so the frame is made with head,
um,
in Minnesota and the front end from the head tube forward is made by envy in
Utah.
And,
uh,
it's just been a great partnership and having their expertise,
um,
to add,
uh,
has really made the project happen the way it has.
Um,
and then we'll get into the numbers because we always liked numbers.
so in the end in terms of the frame stiffness,
uh,
we've actually improved the head tube stiffness,
which is the front end stiffness of the frame.
Um,
and uh,
the BB stiffness is the same as a p five.
Um,
and we found that those are,
those are very positively received.
A big part of that is the frame has made an all one piece,
one continuous piece,
no bond joints,
uh,
in the middle of tubes.
Um,
so that's really helped us create a,
a very strong system.
The other thing we wanted to know does that,
uh,
this is not designed to be a suspension,
a beam kind of ride.
This is a,
this is a stiff frame.
Um,
and the deflections are very small at the,
at the beam.
So,
um,
it's not like some of the older beam bikes you may have seen in the past.
Um,
and that combined with through axles at the front and this very stiff front end,
um,
it's really positive on the road.
Okay.
Uh,
and then to get into the air dynamics a bit.
Um,
if you don't know already,
we try and test with a balanced between very consistent wind tunnel,
uh,
procedure and representing real life.
So we find if we test with live writers,
the data is very noisy.
So we use what you see here,
which is a mannequin,
uh,
in position as a mannequin of Dave's a brisky.
And,
uh,
that's how we compare.
In this case,
we want to compare the bike as it's used in real life,
which is in triathlons with stuff on it.
So our test,
um,
that we're presenting,
uh,
primarily for this pike is fully loaded.
So we have three bottles.
We have all the food on it and the tools as well.
Um,
on the p five,
we had to tape on some items to get that full capacity,
whereas on the p five x were able to contain everything in the frame.
So the result is that,
um,
we met our goal,
we're faster than the p five.
Um,
and,
uh,
on average 30 grams faster,
um,
across the 15 degree Django sweep,
which is the range of a wind angles to the bike depending on what kind of
crosswind you're riding it.
Okay.
Um,
so now,
um,
video.
Okay.
Well I'll take you through,
um,
really for,
as you've seen,
this is a focus on personalizing your bike,
making it for the rider and um,
it's,
it's about the experience with the bike,
not the bike on his own and you'll kind of see that in the video as well.
Okay.
All right.
Um,
so today that's our presentation,
but we've gotten a bit of time for questions I think with the disc brakes.
Can you use a dis squeal or do you you sacrifice that by yes,
there they are starting to make desk wheels with test breaks.
Um,
so that,
that is an option for sure.
I just had a question with regards to the vibration damping at the seat.
I'm just wondering if what the cantilevered monocoque design,
if it's better or worse than the p five from the rider perspective.
Maybe that's a question.
Yeah,
that's a really interesting question.
Um,
I think,
you know,
Sarah might be able to talk a little bit about how she feels about it,
but,
um,
generally the,
the deflections at the saddler are very small.
Um,
but there seems to be an effect of less of,
um,
vibration transfer in terms of a road texture kind of feel.
And so some people have commented on a comfort aspect that they feel it's more
comfortable.
Um,
but it's not floating around.
it's not like you're changing your leg length by a significant amount and that's
what we want to avoid.
Yeah.
I mean,
when I,
uh,
I was riding the bike and in the race and beforehand,
I mean,
one of the things I initially noticed,
and I think a lot of us noticed,
you wrote it where was,
how smooth the ride was and how little vibration that we felt.
Um,
but also as he said,
being able to maintain that stiffness,
which was something that was really important to all of us.
You're given that you have,
you showed the,
uh,
the UCI box that you needed to conform to then.
Yeah.
So,
given that,
how do you get away with not having the Rear Triangle and be compliant on the
roofs days?
Uh,
you mean like how are we UCI complaint without having a rear steer?
We're not,
oh yeah.
No,
but that's a good question.
You're like,
that's our intentional diversion from the UCI.
So there's a separate line now for this UCI illegal bike.
Yeah,
sorry,
I was so,
yeah,
my question was about UCI also.
So what's the,
who's the intended audience for this?
I mean,
is this,
is this for iron man triathlons or Olympics or which direction are you going in?
Yeah,
definitely.
Uh,
triathletes,
um,
long distance track athletes.
Um,
and uh,
well,
yeah,
some Olympic yet for sure.
Um,
but yeah,
we're,
we're not targeting that,
that tt racer with this bike.
That's our p five would provide that.
A question on how you,
uh,
came up with the final selection of the y frame design after he did all the
typical topographic iterations,
it showed that it didn't look like the beam style frame was the coaches.
It's strictly for aerodynamics.
Did you take into consideration,
I guess the original Cervelo,
the green one with Baraki?
Oh yes.
Was that one of the considerations from the research of back then?
When is this?
Yeah,
that's an interesting question.
So
the,
he was not a driving a design inspiration.
It was kind of a fund result when we started realizing that hey wait,
this kind of looks like the first Cervelo,
but definitely not a driving factor.
Um,
the uh,
really,
you know,
as the storage and the bottle placement that was driving more than anything.
Um,
when we,
when I showed those different configurations for,
um,
having sort of a seat tube and no top tube or having the top tube and no c to
both those were contenders aerodynamically.
And so we were really trying to balance everything at once to come up with this.
So this one was helping us structurally versus the other orientation.
Um,
uh,
doing very well.
I are dynamically and then also giving us this option for this optional storage
volume
you think's the most for the great presentation.
Uh,
I remember you were supposed to release the bike around like six months ago and
we knew decided,
no,
we're not going to get your leads from six months and it's probably coming.
You can talk openly about it,
but I'm just curious if you have some more color about what,
what,
why did you decide to delete and what you would probably since then.
Yeah.
Is it,
um,
it's no one big thing in particular.
I'm calm.
Some people were saying,
oh,
did you decide at the last minute to add disc brakes or something like that.
Um,
it wasn't,
it wasn't that kind of decision.
It was really just making sure that we're at the point where we're happy with
the product,
getting all those little things right.
Making sure,
you know,
we're,
we're going through all are very stringent tests.
Um,
and,
and just making sure we had it and available and available and available.
Like on the day of the launch,
we had how many bikes sick,
80,
80 bikes in the stores.
Um,
so then they could bring them out and have them on display and sell them.
And so we really wanted that to be ready,
ready as well.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's very true.
Just to add on to it,
the travel keys for example,
it wasn't ready at all,
so that's sort of the,
all the details that probably we are also busy.
You,
you saw that it's a big part of the story.
It's an accessory yet it's a big part of the story.
The availabilities or so key.
In the past we never launch a bike,
which is there for lunch available right on for every market globally.
So you said 80 but it's a 120 all over the world,
so that has never happened.
That's 80 shops and hundred and 20 bags which we are available on the force and
that we continue to make.
Obviously in the US it's all about details as useful,
so everything was there,
but just to refine everything,
you know and that's nice.
Why we decided to wear it.
It was a marketing decision,
not engineering.
And also probably a marketing mistake to say we already,
when we realized maybe we are not,
I'm saying that because I'm,
I'm in charge of the marketing part.
Uh,
I have a question about the foreign bottle.
Basically it's a bottle need to be a mountain to be to drink,
right?
But there are bottles with a small tube that you can just drink.
So is the prop your proposal to have this kind of Basel III or is sample
and like any bottle it can be,
yes.
Good question.
So what we wanted was we didn't want to restrict anybody to a certain type of
bottle that you couldn't just pass away while you're writing.
So we're showing it with round bottles because that's the lowest stress option.
You can grab a bottle of Gatorade bottle,
generic Gatorade or a water bottle and stick it in and toss that one before you
get to the end of the aid station.
But at the same time,
if you want to run those kinds of bottles,
then that's great because,
uh,
if he,
if you know,
maybe you have a mixed drink that you can to keep there the whole time,
um,
then you can choose to do that and you have that Straw and you maybe you can
stay more Arrow when you use that.
So we definitely recommend like choosing the bottles that you want to use.
But we didn't want to design our own bottle that you had to,
you had to use all the time.
A quick question for you said 120 available worldwide.
What's,
uh,
what is your runway look like?
If you can even talk about that.
When will the bike be available?
Are you going to ship it like this or will be frame only like talk about
configuration and PR and actually how much does it cost?
It's a very good,
uh,
so it's already available.
And if,
if you go around here,
we are,
we're working with beyond a,
so it's like actually you can already go there and actually I think already won
your chase one bike.
That was two days ago or three days ago.
Uh,
so how much,
so it comes exactly like it is okay with those envy weaves some eat up,
uh,
every scene except butter cage.
So meaning many,
everything that comes with it,
everything including even this also.
So travel case comes as an accessory.
And so like this again and view is Samit up $15,000 available now.
Starting later in December.
First of this umbrella,
we'll also have it with you.
We'll take out the ITU headwinds and uh,
auto crank at fifth at $11,000.
Okay,
so any doesn't come as a,
as a frame set it,
Kim's like,
it comes like this
and the bag,
the bag is $849.
Um,
I want to ask a question.
I don't know if,
you know,
our,
our friends down in Morgan Hill came up with a,
uh,
another answer to UCI and their rules.
Um,
as a concept pike I think you guys to great.
They actually made it to market,
but they had some funny ideas,
like really,
really big back wheels.
I was wondering if you guys saw the f Uci bike and ideas about how they had
approached it,
where I,
you guys had.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean for us,
you know,
it's balancing taking the big risks and making something that we can actually
get to market.
Right.
Just like you said.
Um,
you know,
we're,
we're always choosing what things are going to take on.
There's,
there's a lot of things that are still on the wall in the office.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
I'm thinking I'm happy with sort of the approach,
how far we went with it.
Yeah.
I have a question about the aerodynamic comparison that you did with the p five.
Um,
so I think what you said was that you,
you load this bike fully up,
just like the average person would load up their bike and then you load it up
the p five in the same way.
But I guess for the foster people,
I don't think they load up their bikes.
Just like the average person,
they don't take like five things to the front tube and stuff like that.
Right.
So in that case,
is,
is the different still 30 grams or is it,
is it less?
Yeah,
so we find that,
um,
it's more distance related,
I would say then speed related.
Um,
there's definitely some of our pros that have a lot of stuff that they take with
them.
Um,
but um,
what's neat is that we also compared the bikes with nothing on them.
So like a very clean,
lean set up as you would do,
like a,
a t t I guess.
Um,
even though that's not the intended use.
and even in that case,
um,
we're just a little bit faster than a p five.
Okay.
So,
um,
that's kind of neat that it doesn't matter the situation.
Um,
it's still,
uh,
an aero bike.
Yes.
Um,
and just to talk a little bit about that.
So for,
uh,
for me in an Ironman,
I usually carry,
um,
five packages of cliff box and five Giles with me cause I eat 300 calories an
hour.
Um,
and so on the p five,
previously I would have had a bento box in the front,
next lab at Toebox,
um,
that I would put stuff into.
But I was typically taping,
uh,
for gels or four or five jobs onto the top tube here.
And then another two or three jobs on to,
um,
just until the stem,
the stem.
Um,
so in,
um,
the race on Saturday,
I fit all of my nutrition into,
um,
into the box with the exception of one gel,
which I put just on my sports bra.
So it was,
um,
it was a lot more convenient,
from that perspective and um,
and very accommodating.
And so I think,
you know,
as you were saying,
for people who maybe it not be as fast,
they might bring like sandwiches with them and then they can put that in the,
you know,
in the box over there.
You're not going to fit the sandwich necessarily.
And,
and yeah.
You know,
but,
um,
but we still do need to carry quite a bit of nutrition and,
and it really does accommodate that even for people who are faster.
I really want to thank David and steal from the team and everybody else sits
here.
And if we could give him a big round of applause.
[inaudible].